when you're all these kind of big cast
shows it doesn't always happen that you
guys audition and then get the job
you're auditioning for so did you all
audition and get the roles that you
wanted or did the proofs of step in and
play around a bit
they played her out of it for sure I
remember auditioning for Chris Victor
yeah I auditioned for mags and flash but
I did get the role I wanted I to
audition for flash our character names
were different at the beginning I was
supposed to be grace Carter and he was
supposed to be Romeo's esperanza or
something I pretty much walked in and
and fell over and with all my props and
that's how I got the role acting but
that's the thing right like sometimes
acting jobs go really well and you do
the addition and you go when you walk
out and you're like I got this what was
all the addition processes like for you
did any of you leave going oh god
they're never gonna hire me I'm never
gonna but no I think I think it was
pretty run-of-the-mill as far as the
process was for for most of us I own the
audition for Emily I thought it went
alright and then you know we slowly sort
of started to see or hear what was
coming together but it wasn't until we
were all in the first read-through
together that we actually met everyone
met at the same time
in the room and someone walked in I
think it was John McDonald and said well
you guys are the best of the best you
guys are the ones we've narrowed it down
to but we don't know who's playing what
yet so come in and read for various
roles and we and you know that was when
we were reading for each other's roles
and then they just kind of said you know
you're gonna be Kody you're gonna be
Victor etc etc and and they took a
picture they took the first black cast
photo at that callback and Aaron is in
it hi Aaron statement yeah but most of
us was I guess you guys weren't later
yeah Jaime and I realized that even when
I came out lab counselor yes let's let's
not go in a show called Erik's world in
this very building actually way back and
we knew each other from kids in action
Natalie go to kids in action a kids
theater school so the fact that some of
you have these previous relationships I
mean people at home probably think while
watching TV that everyone likes each
other and I mean you guys definitely do
like each other I've been spending time
with you backstage but was it love at
first meeting did you all get along what
was the vibe like when you did start to
work together I mean it's you've got
eight I mean in the beginning absolutely
it was like we're we're young were in
Montreal we're going to work to do what
we love to do every day it was exciting
and it was that you know we were having
a great time cut to about three quarters
first way through the first season and
it was definitely more like look we were
a family at that point so it was like
you're kind of annoying me today
shooting in high school and so you we
started acting like high school kids
like it just had became C we would hear
the bell ring for lunch and we had
lockers it was just practice we became
like almost more immature than we were
yes stayed exactly the same no we shared
the thing that I think it will find
funny and I find funny thinking back on
it now we had 2 dressing rooms a guy's
dressing room
favor actual classrooms in the high
school the divisions between our four
sections were made out of cardboard I
think right we were all like temporary
walls it was traditional sense at
setting where everyone you know when
you're not on set you go to your trailer
or whatever no we were like in class all
the time and each other's faces are
being altogether as close as you were I
mean I mean you weren't teenagers but
you're young people did the friendship
bearers ever blur where their
relationships that happen behind the
scenes and they're so let's talk about
it before and then we go on the show and
then the characters were coming together
was wonderful oh yeah record is saying
that at one point or another I was in
love with everyone that I need to date
somebody before a job breakup while your
characters are now supposed to be
falling in love what was that like and
what like how did you get through that
every day and we and we are still very
close it was a life lesson for me
actually though it was very difficult
yeah for me yeah I know it was difficult
for Katie it was um
but we got through it I mean we were
professionals and absolutely I don't
think it ever affected the production no
that's not what I want to believe what
was it like when they were going through
that for you guys were you put when my
first met at the after that first
audition that we were talking about Ross
gave me a lift back to Toronto because
we were all in Montreal actually part of
the reason why we I think all bonded
together is so many of us were away from
home and so we just hung out with each
other all the time but Ross was giving
both Katie and I ride back to Toronto
and I was in the backseat and Katie and
Rossler in the front I didn't know that
they were too
Andrew Ross reached over and put his
hand on Katie's lap and Katie took his
hand and put it right off of her lap and
I was like what is going on what a dog
yeah so I was in the backseat witnessing
all this I'm like our mom and dad
fighting again but so we were there to
witness all of the back-and-forth but
you know they're absolutely right by by
the end of it every night and by the end
of it like all throughout they it was
always you know they all stay always
stay friends were you guys the only ones
though words are any did anyone else
secretly is there something you guys
want to admit now I'm glad you say
secretly I couldn't date anyone clad one
of the production designers backstage
you said no swearing don't tell me not
to do something no I'll tell you this we
joking aside who was it was love at
first sight I think for pretty much all
of us and that's I think the reason why
we're all sitting here now